who's to blame lots of people are to
blame the leadership of jids is to blame
and they should take responsibility for
the decisions they did and didn't make
the leadership of the Tavistock trust
are to blame for not taking seriously
enough the concerns that were brought to
them by a sizable number of Staff
working in that service who were not
transphobic who were relaying clinical
concerns safeguarding concerns safety
concerns and potentially Child
Protection concerns about the young
people they were caring for
how did you feel before releasing this
book and during the research what did
you think the sort of response was going
to be like upon revealing your
investigation and what it actually been
like since it's come out
think the week weeks and months prior to
publication were the worst
and it had been years of work and it's a
bit like
it was a bit like a third baby really
I've got two kids and you know you take
your baby out into the world and you
want people to to love it obviously not
the way that you do and uh
I love my children more than my work but
I was really nervous about how it would
be received and and the response that I
would would get as well and I have to
say I've been so
pleasantly surprised in that the the
response has been overwhelmingly
positive I mean there have been
favorable reviews on the left on the
right of British politics I've spoken
with Public Service radio in Australia
the first time the ABC have really
looked at this topic
acknowledging that you know people do
have concerns about the evidence base in
particular I've spoken to NPR over there
in the states
um
and I think when you get favorable
reviews
um for your British viewers you know
from The Guardian newspaper from The
Observer from the new Statesman but also
from the telegraph the made on Sunday
the Sunday Times the times you know it
really speaks to the what I was trying
to do with this book which is this is a
health story it's not an ideological
story I'm not a cultural warrior in any
way it's about whether the best care was
always provided to each and every one of
the young people being seen at that
gender Clinic
it seems like
for the very well-meaning people who are
trying to raise well-meaning concerns
around
the ability to consent the effectiveness
of different treatments the
um confusion both on both sides of the
consultant desk around how this stuff
works that because it is so
ideologically heated it's incredibly
difficult and also it this decision I
would actually say that some of the
people on the right have made this a
more difficult conversation to have
because of how inflammatory and how
reactionary some of their conversations
have been because it's very easy to
lambaste anyone who decides to criticize
this so oh you must be one of those
reactionary far-right people you just
want you know all trans people to die
you go well
I can see why uh treading carefully as
it seems like you have done has
hopefully managed to even out the uh the
balance between left and right
I think so but but also I mean just the
way that I've approached the story and
that we approached it at newsnite where
this started has always been
you know we've tried to be calm we've
never questioned
people's identities or the right to
transition it's not ever been about that
it's about as I say about the standard
of care and I think sometimes as you
mentioned the language used when
this or related issues are discussed is
really unfortunate and what I've tried
to keep in mind the whole time while
writing was you know we're talking about
children and young people
and we need to
you know be really careful in our
language and
often those young people are really more
stressed and
it doesn't help to to speak in really
inflammatory terms I think it's far more
heated in the states than it is here
obviously it's very divisive here as
well but we don't have
you know you mentioned sort of the
Evangelical right and the hard right who
want to who deny the existence of trans
people and perhaps want to take away all
care and I don't think we have that here
in the UK no I would agree
um for the people that are just in the
UK and think that this is a very heated
topic turn that Volume Up by 10 times
and that's what you've got over here in
the US okay so what is the story of gids
wow I had to start
well it started off as a
it was the brainchild if you like of a
Child and Adolescent psychiatrist called
Dominico de chaylee and he was really
moved by a single example a young person
he was seeing in the early 1980s
who was female born but
strongly identified as male and was very
distressed about being in this female
body
and that example and a couple of others
that he saw in his work as a
psychiatrist in Croydon sort of South
London
gave him this idea that there had to be
a specialist service for these young
people
who had this what he called a very rare
uh condition where there was this
mismatch potentially between biological
sex and and how they identified and he
succeeded in opening this service in
1989 at a South London Hospital called
St George's and then it moved to its
current home the Tavistock and Portman
in 1994. and and really for quite a long
time the numbers were very small
the service was about talking therapies
about trying to help those children and
young people
explore their gender identity to
understand it to reduce their distress
to help them manage uncertainty
um there was also they did some work in
schools about sort of trying to break
down stigma
and what he noticed even in those very
early days was that often
young people would obviously they'd have
their gender related distress but they'd
also sort of have quite a few other
difficulties as well and while it was
never the aim of the service to try and
change someone's gender identity or to
sort of push them one way or the other
he noticed that sometimes by exploring
someone's gender and kind of trying to
help the distress being brought by the
other conditions perhaps sort of
depression anxiety or what have you then
it might actually relieve that gender
related to stress at the same time so it
was a very cautious slow approach and
what we know as colloquially as puberty
blockers they were available in the
1990s but to 16 year olds only so you'd
pretty much had to have gone through
puberty
um by the time you could have them and
the idea was that they would help to
prepare the body
for those who wanted to transition and
prepare the body for the administering
of of cross-sex hormones or gender
affirming hormones
um
and it was acknowledged at the time that
adolescence well it's acknowledged by by
professionals who work with young people
adolescence is a great time of fluidity
and the gender incongruence in children
was not quite the same as it
is in adults in that it it might not be
fixed and actually in some guidelines
that Domenico to Charlie wrote In the
late 90s it actually stated that
professionals working with these young
people should be mindful that
um
strength of feeling might not indicate
permanence if you like you know that it
was still even if someone felt very very
strongly it it might not be that that
they would feel that way forever
uh and then the service
sort of remained quite small and then in
the 2000s
it became under increasing pressure to
provide those medications to to younger
aged people and that was essentially
because a team in the Netherlands had
started doing that
um and jids was the second is the second
oldest gender clinic for for children
and young people just after the
Netherlands
second oldest in the world yeah in the
in the world yeah wow
so I think there's a Dutch opened in 87
I believe
and um yeah jids opened in 89. and there
weren't very many people working in this
field and and as we went through the
2000s
pressure grew on the service it appeared
there were some very early data coming
back from the Dutch team and it appeared
that there was something here that would
help this very small group of young
people who were very very distressed who
had
their gender incongruence from early
childhood and it had persisted and was
consistent throughout and and had
intensified with the onset of puberty
and
it's it's it's a misnomer that pressure
solely came from from young people and
families and and perhaps sort of
trans-friendly groups it came from all
quarters it came from them certainly but
it also came from
other clinicians working in this field
it came from those working in adult
gender clinics
who said look we we deal with those
those adults who have had to go through
puberty and it's really distressing in
some cases and it came from
endocrinologists as well and so
they took a they they still had concerns
like the concerns that that they had at
the time was
what impact blocking puberty at the
younger age could have on Bones because
puberty is the time where our bone
mineral density is increasing at its
fastest rate so if you stop that what's
the impact going to be longer term and
we still don't really know that we know
it's not good to stop it but when you
reintroduce hormones to the body whether
that's our naturally occurring ones or
synthetic ones it does increase again
but we don't know whether you actually
would
have hit the peak that you would have
had you not interrupted it we don't know
that yet
um and they were concerned about what
impact it might have on
development you know your sexual
identity on brain all these other things
and those those concerns didn't go away
but but they were they were under
pressure and actually
there was an ethical argument that here
is a treatment that might be very
beneficial to this group of young people
let's proceed on a cautious basis we
want to try and add to this evidence
base because there aren't much data so
let's try and
monitor a selected group of young people
and and see what the results are so
that's what they set out to do in 2011.
and they ran This research study they
recruited 44 young people from from the
age of 12.
over the next three years
um and then sort of quite strikingly
rather than wait for that data to come
back in 2014 just after they had
recruited the last young person to the
study so they'd only just started the
blocker they
they rolled out early intervention as it
became known as policy across the
service
um how young is early intervention well
at that point it was 12 but what they
did in 2014 was not just roll it out and
make it to anyone who fitted certain
criteria but but as not part of a study
but they actually did away with that
younger age limit altogether so they
moved from what was called a
an age approach to a stage approach so
providing someone had reached what they
call Tana stage two of puberty which is
pretty early puberty
um so for girls it you you could have
been you could be in town of stage two
for example but have not started your
periods
um it's it's that early and provided you
in Beach town of stage two you could
potentially go on to puberty blockers so
for example in in girls in particular
who tend to start puberty earlier that
could be as young as as nine or ten
and certainly
um data that that jids have presented
publicly has shown that
um they've referred a night you know a
nine-year-old for for puberty blockers
and ten-year-olds have have started on
puberty blockers not not many but they
have
okay so that's 2014.
um yes
this is
same time that
widely available this coincided with a
really quite rapid increase in the
number of young people being referred
um and we saw this rise in absolute
numbers so from 2009 or 9 10 the
financial year
97 referrals to to tajids
sorry had that been relatively flat
throughout the 2000s uh
well it had grown but not
you know it's quite steadily and some
years it went up and so yeah yeah so it
wasn't it wasn't huge I mean it
it had gone up it it did double one year
which year was it
from memory I can't I think it might
have been about 2005 potentially went
from 20 something to 50 odd but but it
you know it was relatively small and and
so we had this 97 in in 2019 and then it
it went up 50 per annum
until 2015 where it doubled
and
that was beyond anybody's expectations
so what number does 2015 get us to how
many people is that so there's a 1400
and something
um and so not only do they
see this really quite rapid increase in
referrals but there had been a really
dramatic shift in the demographics of
the referrals at the same time
so where has whereas previously the
majority of those referred had been boys
biological males
um who had often had sort of lifelong
gender dysphoria or gender incongruence
what happened over that five-year period
or so is that the girls then equaled for
the first time around 2011 and then
massively overtook the boys so by 2015
it was two-thirds female in terms of
referrals and they tended to be
girls who didn't have this sense of
lifelong gender incongruence but really
they're gender related distress had
started
after
the onset of puberty in adolescence
and they often were contending with
quite serious other problems as well
like eating disorders suicidal ideation
depression anxiety some had suffered
physical or sexual abuse
um so they're really quite complicated
young people
and
this is really when clinicians working
there started to worry because
the evidence base for using the puberty
blockers was limited anyway that's why
they set out to do the study in the
first place to try to add to it because
we didn't really have much data there
was a bit more by this point from the
Dutch but it's still it's one one gender
Clinic
but what jids was now doing was
applying a medical treatment
for which had a low evidence base to
start with to a completely different
cohort of young people for whom they
what really was no evidence that it
worked and and actually the leaders of
the service were quite open about that
and they spoke to the UK parliament in
2015 and in their evidence they said we
have extended the use of physical
interventions to those for whom there
isn't a robust evidence base
we're not seeing the young people that
are in the Dutch study
but
we think
it will benefit them now
it was well intentioned but it wasn't
evidence-based at that point and and and
the evidence really
never came to support the widespread use
of puberty blockers for for this cohort
of young people and we haven't really we
haven't seen that from other gender
clinics either and and
a year later
a 2016 some some
the initial data started to come back
from that that study
which
showed that at that point every single
one of the young people who'd gone on
the blocker and who was eligible to go
on to cross-sex hormones the next stage
of a of a medical transition had done so
and for some clinicians
you know as one clinician in the book
said that was that was their holy [__]
moment because it exploded this idea
that they
were telling families and that they had
been led to believe themselves that the
blocker was providing time and space to
think which made perfect sense
like the idea that someone is very
distressed about their developing body
that's not the gender they identify with
so if you pause the body's development
then that made sense that you would
pause the distress and allow allow time
to think but
some people started to question well you
know what are the odds of
Adolescence in particular having time to
think but then all thinking the same way
like generally that's not something we
see
and moreover
when young people were approved for the
blocker
that they were given no space to think
either by the service because rather
than
increase the amount of time they spent
talking with professionals and using
that time
in fact the frequency of appointments
went down and they saw the service less
often
so for some
it made
it just totally changed the way they
practiced
they they saw that actually their
decision to refer someone for puberty
blockers and I say refer because jids
doesn't prescribe they refer and then
some endocrinologists at two other
hospitals do the prescribing
that decision became much much more
serious because if it was the case as it
appeared to be that those young people
would almost inevitably go on to
cross-sex hormones then stations needed
to be had before you started the blocker
about what transition might look like
what
someone should expect from physical
transition
the irreversibility of cross-sex
hormones
what was known what was not known and so
this this was a real turning point it
seems like the puberty blockers become
much more of a a one-way Street or a set
of train tracks that once somebody gets
put on them it's rare that they're going
to deviate
well it's really difficult to know for
sure because what we don't know is
that we don't know that going on the
puberty Blocker in some way causes
someone to
stay fixed in their identity and
therefore
um to go on to the next stage and we
don't know that because of the way the
studies are designed we can't infer
cause and effect
but that is certainly
what clinicians believe that it might be
and you can't really say any more than
might but it might be that somehow
pausing
development or or blocking puberty might
in some way lock in an identity and stop
it from changing where it might have and
it might not have in all people and I
think it's really important to stress
that for any group of
children and young people who
have gender and congruence from the
studies that exist in the past there
have always been some that went on to
transition as adults so no one was ever
questioning that but there have always
been a group that haven't as well and
that tended to be the larger group but
but the the concern
actually initially about
blocking puberty earlier was this
whether you would
somehow lock in an identity that might
have changed if you didn't do it and
that was something that was acknowledged
by the Dutch team that pioneered this
approach they talked about sort of
slightly
unfortunate phrase but they talked about
something they call false positives that
if you blocked earlier you might end up
with these false positives I.E people
who wouldn't have transitioned had they
not gone on the blocker
um it's quite a euphemistic way of
putting it but um so it was always
acknowledged that this might happen we
don't know whether that is what's
happening and jids would say well look
it's not surprising that all those young
people went on to to cross-sex hormones
because we really carefully screened
them and we judged we only for that
study
referred those for whom we thought were
most likely to persist and
become trans adults in transition
because
they'd had this this lifelong gender
incongruence and we assessed really
carefully and and we're just really good
at this and and that's why
we got the results that we had and I
think there are a couple of problems
there in that
there are named professionals who took
part in some of those assessments who
say actually our assessments weren't
that good and I did assessments that
weren't that good and it's not very
common for human beings to admit they
made mistakes and I think when people
appear to their name for it there seems
to be no incentive for for someone to do
that other than it being true
and I think the second difficulty is
that while that may have been the case
for that small group of 44 young people
um although as I've said
clinicians who took part in those
assessments have challenged that but
even if you accept it for those 44
it it seems to be the case that the vast
majority of young people
period go on to take cross-sex hormones
and these were not the young people who
were carefully screened and had lifelong
incongruence and and what have you so
there are there are a couple of
difficulties there have you got any idea
of how many patients were arriving at
gids versus how many were being given
puberty blockers
really really difficult to put a number
on it and this is
I have tried very very hard as have many
other people to ask jids and the
endocrinologists at both
University College London hospitals and
Leeds teaching hospitals where the
endocrinologists are based how many
young people have been referred and then
prescribed puberty bloggers
the honest answer is we don't know
from what is in the public domain it
would seem about
I put it about 17 1800.
um we know that in 2017
in response to a freedom of information
request jid said that they had referred
um
1261. so that was 2017. now there was a
period where not much happened at all
because of of legal disputes
um there was a paper published last
summer which which gave some some more
figures for 2017 to 19.
and and adding those up together with
some data that I received back from from
from one of the hospitals I would say it
sort of
yeah minimum 17 1800 which which might
not sound like a Euro across all of them
across since since 2011 or since or
potentially since um
it was nationally commissioned in 2009
but but really there was so few in those
early years anyway because they weren't
available
um that might not sound very many so we
think they've seen in that time about
ten thousand so it's about
about 20 but I think it's quite
misleading to look at it that way and
because it's it's
I think it's more fruitful potentially
and and this is what
jids haven't really answered is to look
at what how many of the people that were
eligible were referred
because there's a there's one graph in
the book
and this is kind of the best data we
have which is really kind of poor in
itself and this is from 2018 and it it
shows the proportion of young people
who had been referred to the clinic
between
2010 and 2013 who by 2017 had been
referred to Endocrinology so for puberty
blockers and what you can see very
clearly is sort of a belt a classic bell
curve that at both ends of the age
distribution the very young and the Very
Old you have quite low proportions so
you know the three four five year olds
um
who were referred during that time
um they wouldn't have been eligible
basically because they hadn't started
puberty so that kind of rules them out
16 and 17 year olds the 17 year olds in
particular very low proportion because
there's not really much Point going on a
puberty blocker you can go straight onto
Adult Services and and have hormones
direct so and that's clinicians say that
happened quite a lot the the older ones
would say because the rules here not not
in the States but the rules here were
even if you were 50 and 16 17 you had to
go on puberty blockers for a year before
you could go on hormones
um you could never go straight onto
hormones so so lots of people just
waited for Adult Services but what you
see in the middle these kind of
adolescent years
is
very high proportions of young people
who were referred
between the ages of 11 and 15 were then
referred
for blockers
and those who were referred in that time
period 2010 to 13 who were 14.
in fact about about 70 of them did so
averages can be very misleading
and you know for years jid's put out a
figure in the public domain they gave it
in loads of loads of interviews they
said about 40 of the young people
are referred for puberty blockers and of
those who we see who referred Under 12
it's about 20 to 25 percent
which you don't have to be a
mathematical genius to work out well if
the average overall is about 40 and the
under 12s is about 20 then it sort of
implies that the over 12s is about 60.
you know just basic maths
um and and those proportions have come
down but really
without the actual proper data in the
public domain or we can surmise is
these are my best estimates isn't this
place run by the NHS
yeah
is that not owned but I mean how is this
not Freedom of Information like it's
literally owned by the British
government
yeah it's not owned by the British
government but I know what you're saying
I mean
there have been countless Freedom of
Information requests asking for this
data and the response is we don't have
it or we have it but it would take far
too long for us to get it because that
information NHS absolutely screams NHS
well this is this is the individual
trust so so they've been asked on many
and you know occasionally they've given
us bits of data like that that 1261 that
that came from a freedom of information
request
um and I have personally
um FOID the trust and and the
Endocrinology hospitals and they haven't
provided it
um they must have it and and and
it is in those patient records obviously
if a Young Person's been referred but I
I think also concentrating solely on the
physical interventions
only tells a fraction of the story I
mean you know we don't know what's
happened to those who weren't referred
for them while it did we don't know
whether they're gender distress resolved
and if so how and what they're doing now
we don't know how many went on to Adult
Services we don't know how many people
are happy we don't know how many people
are not happy
um we don't know much at all given that
this is an incredibly
serious intervention that has lifelong
repercussions this is the sort of thing
that tracking
would have been pretty useful for just
how effective is this sort of
intervention just how effective is it to
not intervene can we do talk therapy can
we do other things that don't lock in
this set of train tracks down Okay so
am I right in saying that
kids only
all that they did was refer for puberty
blockers they weren't doing
um they weren't referring for surgery
they weren't referring for anything else
was the sole thing that they did refer
for puberty blockers yeah they had
absolutely nothing to do with surgery so
everybody they saw was under 18 and
um while I believe that you can get
double mastectomies now at 17. no they
they have nothing to do with that that's
solely Adult Services so they would
refer for puberty blockers and this is
the key thing that that from
around 2014 also when they became in
their own words an assessment service
there was no other
treatment pathway that they offered so
they didn't they they weren't offering
extended ongoing talking therapy like
you say
they would assess for suitability for
physical interventions and that's not to
imply that the majority were referred
onto that but they weren't offered
anything else really either
our puberty block is reversible because
that's something that I've heard claimed
the honest answer is we don't know I
mean physically
they are
well
the honest answer is we don't know the
official NHS guidance is
little is known about the long-term side
effects of using puberty blockers to
treat this condition because they
function very differently when used
um
engender distressed young people than
they do in the treatment of precocious
puberty for which they are licensed
because in precocious puberty where a
child starts puberty very very early
like way before they're ready
they take the puberty blocker
it pauses the development and then they
stop and then they go through their
body's biological puberty
in
generally speaking as we've already
mentioned
when a young person
experiencing distress about their gender
takes the puberty blocker they don't
stop
they take it and their body never goes
through their biological puberty they
will then go on to
cross-sex hormones and hormones will
return to their body and their bones
will start strengthening again but it's
not it's not their body's natural
naturally occurring hormones so
systematic reviews of the evidence base
have been undertaken here in England
by nice the National Institute for care
and health excellence in Sweden in
Finland and I believe Norway now as well
by
the respected Health bodies the official
Health bodies and in all those cases
where they've undertaken a systematic
review they've found the evidence-based
wanting on the efficacy of using both
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
um
in this area of health care but
physically they are reversible in that
if you stop then yes puberty resumes but
but what we don't know and what's
acknowledged by the NHS in its official
guidance is we don't know what long-term
impact blocking puberty might have on
brain development on cognitive
development on sexuality on the
development of other identities or so we
don't know any of that because the
long-term data doesn't exist and and
interestingly
there's a case study in the book A young
trans man called Jacob
who took the blocker for four years from
12 to 16 was not very well on them at
all and
you know
the argument is yes they're physically
reversible and puberty resumes well he
didn't get his periods for two years
after coming off the blocker and even
now he's 19.
they're not regular
and
surprisingly he's not being monitored at
all there's been no follow-up since he
chose to leave the care of jits so the
statement is made that they're
physically reversible but in fact when
used to treat this condition we really
don't know so few people come off and
then they're not followed that we don't
know and we don't have the long-term
data what about the effectiveness of
puberty blockers for helping with
suffering and suicidality in youngsters
are really quite poor
um the original Dutch studies
argued that
there was a psychological they saw
psychological benefit to to going on the
puberty blockers and and then they
didn't actually measure the sole impact
of cross-sex hormones it was hormones
and surgery and they said the whole
pathway was was beneficial but but when
jids tried to replicate the Dutch within
that study we didn't get those data back
until well very late 2020 in a pre-print
but officially published in 2021 and
actually
when using quantitative measures proper
measurable
stuff they found no psychological
benefit to the young people on puberty
blockers and in fact even by the
the subjective qualitative measures the
the self-reports from those young people
it was a really mixed bag as well so the
the researchers the team reported that
the majority
had a positive experience
um and obviously none wanted to come off
but actually the data it's not really
that strong and even in those
qualitative measures when you look at
those who'd been taking them more than a
year it's about equal proportions some
in terms of about 30 reported or just
under 30 reported positive mood changes
and 30 percent
said negative mood changes and what's so
interesting is that actually they had
data that showed that as far back as
2016 or 2015 even that that for some
people
well there was no improvement and
actually for some people they appeared
to get worse
so
there really isn't
strong data certainly from the UK that
supports the argument that puberty
blockers
improve mental health or reduce
suicidality I know that there are
studies in the states that come out of
the states that claim to show that but
actually
they're pretty methodologically flawed
and they have been quite heavily
critiqued and often don't
actually show what they claim to show
higher up in the paper when you look at
the data so I
yeah I'm
pretty weak it Stacks up a very serious
body of evidence here
um
you have an intervention which may not
impact people in the way that it should
do in the short term it may not have the
reversibility that would make it less of
a big deal in the medium term it may not
fix the problems that are concerning in
the long term and it may also lock these
individuals in to a trajectory that they
can't get out of on the lifelong term
that seems like an incredibly big
decision
to make it should be one that's
incredibly heavily scrutinized it's one
that should take a very long time to to
get to and I understand that when this
intervention or these interventions were
first being rolled out you don't know
what you don't know you don't know just
how serious it is etc etc uh I presume
that the
unknown unknowns and the gaps in
knowledge are precisely where a lot of
the holes uh like people fell through
these holes both in terms of the
clinicians the the consultants and the
patients
yeah and I I think it's really important
to acknowledge that there are
consequences to not acting as well and
you know I've spoken to people for the
book who are very happily transitioned
and they describe puberty blockers as as
life-saving so that is some people's
experience and there is an argument that
um
that some in the trans community and and
trans allies will put forward that
they're not meant to be
um you know antidepressants or anything
they they block puberty and they prevent
a young person going through changes
that that they can never reverse if they
choose to transition as adults
but I think
which is which is true like that is one
one rationale given for the blocker is
that it prevents future surgery and it
makes particularly for for biological
males it makes it easier to to pass as
adults if if if they choose to
transition
I think the difficulty is that that
these various other rationales sort of
the time and space to think and the
improvements in mental health and the
reduction in distress have been given as
the rationale for using the blocker
um by researchers and by gender clinics
and and
so it's
there's sort of Shifting goal posts as
to what we're measuring and and you know
it's almost as if when when the data
doesn't support the original hypothesis
then the hypothesis changes perhaps yeah
um
and I think you're right with the
unknown unknowns and I think when this
started
it was a perfectly
it was trying to help a very small
number of people with a very sort of
specific difficulty
and they proceeded with caution
and they try to add to data try to add
to the evidence base
but when data came back that that didn't
that wasn't consistent that didn't
support what
they believed they didn't
that didn't give pause for thought and
that's what's quite striking so it it
wasn't
and it may well be that that you know
blockers
as I say I've spoken to people for whom
they've been life-saving but it seems
that when they're applied to a
completely different cohort of young
people who
um
you know who never met the criteria of
the Dutch study you know they weren't
psychologically stable they didn't live
in supportive necessarily um you know
stable
home environments and they didn't have
lifelong gender in Congress it's not
really that surprising that you don't
get the same results
and the surprising thing is to roll out
one intervention to a massive group of
people and not think that perhaps
something else might be needed in in
some of those cases and it's not to say
that that some won't benefit from them
but I think I think the evidence base
hasn't really Advanced much in 20 years
yeah it doesn't seem that way given
given the fact that this that the
puberty blockers aren't reversible even
if they were reversible I don't know if
this uh if it changes
this concern
how can it be argued that it is ethical
to allow an individual who is not old
enough to buy a lottery ticket buy a Red
Bull
vote
drive a car with a
teacher in the seat next to you
have sex
watch porn
how is it
possible for that kind of person to be
allowed to consent to any kind of
procedure which could have lifelong
implications
well the argument that
one of the women who led jids for a
decade she retired in 2020 Bernadette
Ren
wrote was that from its outset jids was
not just a therapeutic project it was a
Justice project and it was about
extending
the rights to
live one's life personal autonomy if you
like to to this group of children and
respecting their identity it wasn't
about challenging who they were and and
the argument is that young people know
who they are and
it would be cruel to deny them
the the chance to live is is the person
they they identify and who they strongly
feel themselves to be I mean that that
that's the argument
how many of these young people are just
gay
well
I can't answer that definitively what I
can say
is that from the very limited data that
exists
many of the young people referred to
gender clinics well certainly to the to
to jids
are same-sex attracted or or a bisexual
um so what we know is that actually so
the 70 young people in the Netherlands
who form
who were part of those these two Dutch
study well one Dutch study really but
two tranches
um which forms the basis of all gender
affirming medical care for children
all of the girls in that study all of
the biological females were same-sex
attracted or bisexual none were opposite
sex attracted and one of the boys was
which is quite
striking the data that we have from jids
is that of those referred in 2012 so you
know more than a decade ago now
of the older young people that refer to
12 and up for whom they had data which
was about 100 just under a hundred so
again not not great
um around 90 of the girls
were same-sex attracted or bisexual and
about 80 of the boys roughly and the
only more recent data we have from jids
but we haven't seen any sort of
breakdown it's just on their websites
from about 2015 so we don't know what
the numbers are
but this puts it at about
70 combined for the girls either
same-sex attracted or bisexual and about
60 for the boys so so still very very
high and
this was a a concern that many many many
clinicians had and I want to be clear
that it is not
the soul it's not solely coming from
those clinicians who are themselves gay
uh or lesbian or bisexual it was so
widely
scene and I think
some of those clinicians say that the
the charge was put to them well you're
too close to it because you're gay and
therefore you can't be subjective about
this now now jids would deny that that
happened but but actually
when I put that to them when I when I
spoke to them for the book uh one
clinician Anna Hutchinson she said look
look at the data
that it's not we weren't seeing
something that wasn't there
and okay the data aren't great we only
have a couple of years but but
you know we saw this on a daily basis
young people mainly girls but the boys
as well
sitting in front of us
talking about how they had a
relationship with
someone of the same sex
been homophobe you know experienced
homophobic bullying and then came to
identify as trans
and it wasn't that they were saying that
none of those people could be trans or
they didn't know themselves in any way
they were saying we need to think about
this
and we need to explore
sexuality
as we need to explore gender because
it's noteworthy that in many of the
cases
someone was not just
a transition wouldn't just change their
gender it would also change their
sexuality and they were just saying this
is something we really need to think
about and that they were worried about
and it's another example really in this
story of where
knowledge seems to get forgotten as time
goes on and the clinic became busier
because the old data
tended to show that when you had a group
of
young people who were distressed around
their gender some would grow on to be
trans adults but the majority wouldn't
and the majority of them would would
grow up to be gay and and that seemed to
be
forgotten as time went on and clinicians
said look these behaviors that many of
us are taking as indicators that someone
might be trans they equally apply to
kids that might grow up to be gay like
they're really similar so that's
something we need to bear in mind it
wasn't that they would dream of telling
a young person no your identity is not
what you think it is you're gay it
wasn't like that and of course no one
was intending to
this is all folder converting gay kids
it's
no there was no intention but what they
were saying is we really need to think
about this and at the moment we're not
how many other mental health
complications were the young people
coming into this Clinic suffering with
so we're complicated young people
they were complicated young people with
complicated lives
I mean several clinicians said they
didn't see us a single young person for
whom everything was fine
apart from their gender identity
um you know others disputed that and
they said for some you could you just
knew and there was nothing else it could
be and so therefore
three sessions is fine and you know
that's that's fine
um but but many said that these were the
most complicated distressed and
traumatized young people they'd ever
worked with and some of these were very
very experienced mental health
professionals had worked in numerous
other services
um and that's why they were so worried
because there appeared to be so much
else going on
and and even even if some of those young
people
you know
were trans and would benefit from a
from transitioning and I'm sure some of
those young people have they were saying
they're not in the right
place to do it safely and and some of
those other issues need to be solved
first it wasn't that we're denying
their Identity or the that it could be
the right pathway for them but it just
wasn't safe to do it at that moment in
time with so much else going on
and equally it could be that
the the primary difficulty was not the
gender and that if you solved something
else you know I mean
I don't want to wish to imply that this
was the majority of cases but there were
there were several cases it's documented
in the book where where a trans
identification came quite quickly after
a young person had
suffered a traumatic event or had
potentially been you know sexually
assaulted or sexually abused now what
clinicians say is that
it's quite easy to understand why
someone might
feel distress around their body and
particular parts of their body if
they've been
you know horrifically violated usually
by people you trust
in those parts of the body and therefore
you'd want to change it yeah
um you know and what they were saying
was
that needs to be worked through first
again it's not as black and white as
someone's had a traumatic childhood
therefore they can't be trans and can't
transition they were saying in those
circumstances that that trauma has to be
worked through so that we make sure that
we get this right and they were saying
that too often it didn't happen well
fundamentally the the question here I
think is our young people distressed
because they're trans and aren't fully
living out their desired gender identity
or are they trans because they're
mentally distressed and haven't dealt
with the underlying problem
yeah and it could well be both
depending on on on which young person
you're talking about and it's
interesting taking someone through CBT
or taking them to an anxiety counselor
or a trauma therapist or whatever
psychotherapy
is significantly more reversible
than putting them on puberty blockers
yes I guess the counter argument would
be
if you miss the relevant time window
then
for someone who
will identify as trans for life then
those changes to their body are
very damaging and and irreversible too
so but yes I mean I wonder if the more
uh ideologically are bound
would even see
removing some of the let's say that
there is a non-zero number of people
within this cohort for whom autism OCD
trauma etc etc are precursors to a
gender identity crisis and if the
precursors were removed that the gender
identity thing would fall away
um
I can imagine the more Ardent trans
activists here in the US saying that
that would be something which is
unethical as well that by getting rid of
the precursor this is denying somebody's
foreign
ERS out into the world yeah and and
that's what happened at Jade's in in
that clinicians say that they were
discouraged from
providing what you might call a
differential diagnosis so that to even
suggest that someone's distress might be
as a result of something else other than
being trans was discouraged and seen as
transphobic so so yes I mean that that
is the view of some people
um
didn't you you had a story about a
boy who was showering five times a day
and wouldn't wouldn't leave his room
what was that story
that was an absolutely heartbreaking
story so this is a young teenage boy
was openly gay
um
and yeah I was coming home showering as
soon as he got home from school and his
mum didn't really think that much of it
she just thought oh well I'm blessed
with a really hygienic teenage boy
um rare and
it became very very serious and
she quickly realized that he he had
quite a very severe obsessive compulsive
disorder and sought help from local what
we call cams here in the UK so Child and
Adolescent Mental Health Services
and not long after
he was seen at cams
he blurted out to his mother
you don't understand I'm trans you've
been misgendering me my entire life and
put it into perspective he was
six feet
yeah big big big
very tall you know size 13 feet what
have you as I say openly gay and and
happy to be
and his mum
was just like what you know and it was
2014 it wasn't
she didn't even know what it meant
really
and
from the moment that he had said that
Cam's
would affirm him as female and
um
and set about referring him to gender
Specialists to to Jade and his mum was
like hang on
he's really unwell like even if
this is true he's in no State whatsoever
and and his mental health deteriorated
very very rapidly he got to the point
where he he couldn't leave the house he
couldn't go to school
he the floor of his bedroom had to have
plastic sheets on it he his bathroom
would be flooded
because he was going to the toilet so
much he couldn't keep clean and then the
toilet would flood and it was absolutely
I mean talking to his mum you know eight
years after the event it was
she was in tears and it was very very
distressing and he was so ill that he
couldn't actually attend his
appointments at jid's
and rather than take that as a sign
that perhaps he wasn't well enough to
transition or to consider transitioning
a very senior kids clinician traveled to
his home instead uh well to to nearby
his home
um several hours
um
and
his mom claims that at that very first
appointment not he wasn't offered
blockers but but the subject was was
brought up and and she just couldn't
believe it
and ultimately she took him out and
he had private therapy she lost all
faith in NHS clinicians and said this is
this is just mad basically my son is
really really ill and no one's helping
him
and and then after several years he he
didn't identify as trans anymore and
he's happily gay and has a partner and
their relationship isn't very good he
still has mental health problems but
um but it was just extraordinary that
someone who cannot leave their own home
who who
wanted to cut off their own penis and
saw things crawling up the walls that to
even consider that they would be in a
state ready to transition
you said that less than two percent of
children in the UK have an autism
spectrum disorder and a Jed's more than
a third of the referrals had autistic
traits
yeah
yeah and that's something that that
worried clinicians do because they're
like well
that seems to be very high
I mean the two percent thing I mean
that may well be an underrepresentation
I mean this this debate's had all the
time the the data on on autism autistic
Spectrum disorders is not fantastic but
but yeah I mean that's the best we've
got
um
and again it wasn't they were saying
that no one who's autistic could be
trans it's just with this really high
proportion
exhibiting moderate to severe traits
might we be medicating unnecessarily
autistic kids
and they were really worried about that
because what we know about autism is
that not just on gender but on on on
other things as well you know autistic
people can think very
you know in very black and white terms
and it seemed to those clinicians who
were sitting in the room with those kids
and and their families that
it was a it was potentially a way of
making sense of their world rather than
true you know a true identity and they
just wanted to be as careful as they
could be
what
have you come to believe about why this
2015-16 period
just saw an insane increase in the
number of admissions what what do you
think is going on there and also what
were the downstream implications for
what happened inside of jids
okay so the first part of the question I
think there are lots of things that
explain it I don't think
I can give a definitive answer but I
would I'd say there's there's a load of
factors so jids themselves would would
put this rise down to increased
acceptance of trans people increased
visibility and it being easier to
to come out and put a name to something
I think that might be true for some
people so for example there's a young
trans guy in the book called Jack and
for him that kind of fits him really he
for his entire life since childhood
didn't feel like a girl and really when
he came across the idea of of trans
around sort of 2010
um he said yeah that's me so I
that that might be the case for some
people but it it really
it doesn't explain
the full picture and all I can really
say is what clinicians have told me and
what what Young
um both trans and D transitioned people
have told me which is you know a variety
of things so for some people and and
actually wpath the world Professional
Association of transgender Health which
is based out there in the States and
it's very affirmative even they accept
that for some young people there will be
a social influence to this
to their trans identity and and that we
have to bear that in mind
um and for one of the young people in
the book Harriet that was certainly a
factor for her the fact that many of her
friends were also identifying as trans
or non-binary and it was quite trendy
um at that time for her she also was
having some quite severe mental health
problems
and
she had had a same-sex relationship and
been made to feel quite ashamed about
that and she didn't want to be a lesbian
and the combination of these things and
she was a really heavy social media user
and
in her own words she
she saw a trans identity as a way of
understanding
of of jumping ship but also making sense
of who she was and for a while she was
much much happier she was she went
through this honeymoon period for
several years it wasn't a fleeting
identity and in that time you know she
she took testosterone and had a double
mastectomy and now regrets that but so I
think
so I think that's a host of other
factors and I think particularly for
girls
it's it's it's quite hard being a
teenage girl I mean puberty is quite
difficult anyway I mean but I think now
we have you know hardcore porn is quite
ubiquitous and
I think it's probably difficult being a
teenage girl
when there are certain expectations of
you sexually and perhaps having your
first sexual experience with boys who
have consumed that kind of material
and I think it's hard
[Music]
for some girls who don't
perhaps feel that
you know they don't live up to the
they don't feel Uber feminine perhaps
they don't
they don't fit what they see as
girls should be you know that they're
not doing girlhood properly I think it
can be a really difficult time and I
think all these things perhaps explain
why
a different identity might
might be the answer that would also uh
coincide you know we were talking about
this flip almost that it was mostly
biological men uh males and then you get
this this big sort of liftoff so you go
okay well what's happening to just the
girls uh Advent of social media ubiquity
of online porn
um
expectations or I guess a back end of a
sexual Liberation movement that perhaps
makes sex at younger ages more common
you know
British TV series like skins and stuff
like that you know
it really does put relationships at the
Forefront of a 14 15 16 year olds life
so it doesn't surprise me
no and clinicians you know these are not
my sort of ideas this come but from from
professionals but you know Christians
would also say that that girls in
particular
um and they've noticed this in their
professional careers I mean girls have a
tendency to express distress through
their bodies so whether that's
Eating Disorders cutting
um that tends to
you know it tends to affect girls in
Greater proportions than boys for some
reason
um I remember but also you know I do
want to say that sorry to just very very
briefly that I talked about Jack and I
you know some of the number May well be
that you know some of these people some
of these will will they'll identify that
because they'll grow up to be trans so I
want to sort of acknowledge that as well
yeah I remember
um hearing a story two really
interesting stories recently actually
the first one was
a girl who over ate uh it well well into
adulthood uh and after a ton of therapy
it turned out that she'd been sexually
uh abused when she was younger and what
it seems was happening was this woman
was
making herself into as
um unsexual of an object as possible by
gaining weight so she was using weight
not only physically to create a barrier
around her that made her feel safer but
also
um like figuratively symbolically so
that she wasn't seen in that same kind
of sexual light okay well that's
interesting
and then this other one
um the YouTube channel called kidology
she's a
British YouTuber
hundred and something thousand uh Subs
so it's an interesting Channel
um and there is a common subculture on
the internet at the moment that there's
no such thing as a female in cell that
basically any woman would be able to get
sex it might not be the sex that they
want but it's sex and for men there are
men who want sex and can't get it
therefore there is no such thing as a
female insult and she really changed my
opinion on this because she spoke about
the fact that she had gone through some
trauma not in terms of a sexual assault
but just in terms of like an unpleasant
unenjoyable experience uh that had left
her feeling
um like incredibly averse to sex
so even if she likes a guy even if she
wants to get intimate with a guy she
can't bring herself to do it
and I thought
holy [__] like that
that
type of dynamic that could cause someone
to want to be intimate
but be unable to bring themselves
psychologically to do it like
that takes all of the boxes of incel as
far as I can see uh and
both of those just very interesting
obviously uh as much as I can try to
understand the female psyche much
smarter people than me have done it and
failed but
both of those well I found it really
interesting and insightful around you
know some of the the challenges that I
think are unique to the way that females
minds work
hmm
yeah I mean
I
don't know if I could add anything
really that's such a fantastic story so
okay one of the elephants in the room I
suppose especially for the people that
are listening from America especially
for the people that are listening to
this coming out of the culture War
raging left versus right thing is
how much of a role did ideology play
when it came to the behavior of and
policies at gids
I think it's really
complicated I think it absolutely did
play a role but it's not as blatant as
some would want to believe and and and
and talk about so
there were certain groups
um you know trans groups trans support
groups who were very active and
their presence was certainly felt
um by clinicians at jids and I mean
pretty much
everyone I spoke to
I mean it depends what period of time
you're talking about but the period of
time where the referrals were going up
through the roof and the pressure was
absolutely uh immense to get through the
numbers
um
that there was a particular group called
mermaids but but there have also been
others and more recent years gendered
intelligence is probably the most
influential group but
their presence was felt
and clinicians say
look even even though they weren't in
the room
they were in the room they were in out
they were in our minds we had this
pressure from mermaids all the time and
mermaids were or are a charity which
supports uh gender diverse as they put
it and trans children and their families
and they're very
much in favor of a medical model
um
and they lobbied jids for years both to
introduce the blocker at a younger age
um so in in the 2000s and and then to
reduce the age at which hormones could
be given
and to
relax
um the criteria whereby a young person
had to go on the blocker before going on
hormones
now
it's not the reason I say it's
complicated is because they didn't get
everything that they wanted so those
those two later things didn't really
happen so there wasn't a big reduction
in the age at which hormones could be
given it came down a little bit to
around 16 as opposed to a hard 16 and so
you could be you know 15 and eight
months nine months or what have you but
it didn't really shift significantly
um
but they were influential we know that
the head of that charity would make
requests on behalf of families for a
Young Person's clinicians to be switched
if they weren't getting a referral for
for blockers as quickly as they wanted
and and on occasion I don't know how
often this happened I'm not suggesting
it happened often but it did happen and
those those requests were granted
we know that senior people in The Wider
trust which which housed jids
asked wanted to coordinate the content
of jits website with that of mermaids
and make sure that they were consistent
and get approval for that from from
mermaids
um
and I think there's probably a more
subtle influence that they had which is
it appears that you
when new information came to light
during the course of the work whether
that's information on the blocker and
how it was working you know this
everybody going on to cross-sex hormones
or the vast majority
um or other things that came known for
example the risks to biological males
who had their puberty block too early
who then went on to transition actually
if you block too early it can make it
very very difficult to perform certain
surgeries when information came to light
it wasn't routinely passed on and it
wasn't written down and
the suggestion from from clinicians I've
spoken to is that that was because there
was some kind of fear of a backlash from
these groups
if that information was codified because
it was you know it was scary to tell a
young
male who identifies as female
that
you know surgery could be very difficult
for you uh if we block too early it's
probably not something they want to hear
and and it also makes it much more real
doesn't it you're talking about many
many years in the future
so
I think it's they were influential
they weren't running the show but they
clinicians were definitely aware of them
and
potentially changed their practice
because of them because they were in
their heads
um and I think it prevented jits from
changing direction when perhaps it could
and should have over over the years
because they were
the relationship was too close and and
what clinicians have said is that who've
worked in other places where
you know you have patient groups and
sometimes patient groups come into
conflict conflict with with medical
professionals because
they might want something that actually
is not clinically indicated
um and and what professionals said was
that in other places we saw the service
be able to hold a proper boundary and
they didn't see that happening at jid's
um again the service dispute it but but
it it came up with pretty much everyone
I spoke to even those who spoke
favorably about the service they said
that that mermaids were very influential
but what I what I didn't find and why
I'd say it's more complicated when you
ask about ideology I didn't find that
the vast majority of people working
there were ideologues in any way
I mean there were some but it was the
minority most were just caring
thoughtful professionals who wanted to
do the very best for the young people
sitting in front of them and
so I don't think it was staffed by a
load of ideologues
but it's quite telling that that one of
the people in charge of leading that
service said you know described it as a
Justice project as well as a therapeutic
project
yes the the uh energy the vibe the
um culture trickles down from top to
bottom right yeah you have somebody
leading at the top that essentially
everyone else is responsible to culpable
to answers to so I mean you can say it's
not a bunch of card carrying flag waving
ideologues with foam fingers saying that
we want the trans the kids and all the
rest of it
but it does seem like there is a
pretty big laundry list of errors that
occurred yeah uh it seems like
I have no idea
how malpracticey how calling into
dispute someone's medical ethics and
whatnot this is
but we can definitely say that it was a
sub-optimal like clinical environment I
think
um
who
who's to blame and why why did why did
this
be allowed to happen why given the
especially in the UK as well just for
the people that don't that are maybe
from the US
um you know
to get interventions you know to get
prescribed you can't get prescribed
melatonin in the UK right you can buy 10
milligram tabs on Amazon over here in
the US they they General
patient doctor relationship in the UK is
starkly different to the way that it is
in the US and they're not incentivized
to typically intervene your number of
times I've gone into the doctor I'm sure
it's been the same for you as well
they'll print off a single sheet of
paper give it to you and say like well
you know give this a read and and try
good not using your phone before you go
to bed or or you know stop eating so
much kale or whatever the like whatever
the thing is and then they'll say right
on your way you go
um my point being that they seem to be
uh reticent when it comes to
interventions
and um
most people enter this I have tons of
friends that are doctors and and and
work in the medical industry
I don't think that they would want to go
in to do anything to damage people
and yet it seems like there's been
massive Litany of problems
why did they occur
is there someone that's having the
finger pointed at them
why are there so many holes in this
system
big questions
I think it starts in a way from from the
previous answer and I think where
ideology
the ideology did Trump medical evidence
here so
it may have been and I I'd like to
believe it was well-intentioned that
that there was a desire to help
distressed young people but by expanding
the group for which you refer for
puberty brokers
that was a decision
that may have been well intentioned and
but it stemmed from a belief that you
were helping someone
um
fulfill meet their true identity it
wasn't evidence-based there was no
evidence to support that and actually
data came back that actually challenged
that and and they didn't change practice
and that's what's so
sort of difficult to understand so I
think you know that that is where you
can certainly say that ideology
influence because this was a belief
system really
um it wasn't based on evidence
um it was a belief that they were
helping
um
and as one clinician put it you know
things can be well-intentioned but um
informed
who's to blame lots of people are to
blame
the leadership of jids is to blame and
they should take responsibility for the
decisions they did and didn't make the
leadership of the Tavistock trust are to
blame
for
not taking seriously enough the concerns
that were brought to them by a sizable
number of Staff working in that service
who were not transphobic who were
relaying clinical concerns safeguarding
concerns
safety concerns and potentially Child
Protection concerns about the young
people they were caring for
and really to have taken those concerns
seriously would have needed huge change
and
for whatever reason the leadership of
the trust didn't do that
NHS England is to blame
they
did not provide adequate oversight why
did they allow the
rolling out of the early blocking of
puberty without seeing any
robust data at all
why did they not step in earlier
why when the referrals were going
through the roof and that they saw
that these were very complicated young
people did they think it was sensible to
staff the service were predominantly
Junior inexperienced members of Staff
which is what happened and why when it
was clear that wasn't working did they
not change direction
why did they not act until
2021 in asking someone to undertake a
thorough review an independent review of
this service or this area of care when
they'd heard concerns
for many years and you know at least as
back as 2018 if not before
um
all those people are to blame so are the
media
who for many years did not
um scrutinize this in in the way they
probably should have so are the
politicians who have heard about these
concerns for many years and nothing has
changed and so the healthcare Regulators
who until our work at BBC News night
showed them some of these very very
serious concerns that were related to
the trust during an official review
hadn't inspected it for since 2016 and
then did go in and write it inadequate
so
so many people are to blame
um it it's systemic failure
on quite a large scale
um
why did this happen well
again I don't think it's something that
I can answer definitively I think
it's something I mentioned before that
you know why didn't they change
direction we've talked about this when
it was quite clear that
it probably wouldn't be the right
pathway for all of the young people well
it's very hard isn't it to admit we've
made mistakes it's not something that is
in our nature really as human beings and
I think
Anna Hutchinson puts it this way when
she was talking to the medical director
of the trash she said for someone to
have been
recommending or referring for a
potentially life-changing medical
intervention for a decade or so
what are the implications of admitting
that you may have got that wrong it's
quite intolerable actually potentially
so it may well be that
some of it is explained to the fact that
it's it's it's too hard to
for some people to to admit that this
might not have been the right thing to
do in each and every one of those
young people's cases
I think what clinicians told me on many
occasions was this was just not a
service that operated according to the
normal rules that you'd expect in the
NHS and they said that the word gender
because it was there in this it muddied
the waters
um it meant that it wasn't subject to
the normal oversight that you'd expect
and this is something that Dr Hillary
Cass has pointed out in her interim
findings that it hasn't been subject to
the normal oversight that one would
expect of a service
that that refers for Innovative
treatments for children
um and the usual checks and balances the
usual data collection it's just not been
there
um you know one very senior clinician
said to me
it's almost like for NHS England there
was this cloak of mystery created by a
gender service and it was assumed that
that we were the experts and it was so
special that and we knew what we were
doing
so
and and so the oversight wasn't there
and and I think there were practical
reasons that explain it as well you know
jids was part of what what's known as
specialist commissioning in the NHS
um you know it's it's a specialist
service
and and there are hundreds of them and I
think
for a while it was it was really small
it didn't come across their radar
and I think
some health insiders that I've spoken to
admit they were far too slow to act but
I think for many years it just didn't
figure
and
you know that's not that's not good
enough that's not an excuse and it
doesn't
but but maybe
yeah it's it you know there's no Grand
conspiracy but maybe
it just fell through the cracks
that the fact that there are so many
different parties who
through
fear
habit
negligence busyness
uh distraction whatever
um for a whole host of reasons
um and the fact that there is no single
hooded figure with a long hook nose and
a staff you know that's coordinating all
of this
is
so much more banal
and
um
like less conspiratorially impressive
then I think a lot of people might have
considered but the problem the problem
with it and it's the same way that
intelligence Services work right by
compartmentalizing information you uh
limit any one person from being able to
work out what's going on but by
compartmentalizing inefficiency
what you do is you stop any one person
from being able to fix it because there
are numbers of different vectors all of
these different angles well this
person's [__] and this person's [__] and
this person's [__] and either you know
when you pile it all together it's not
one big mound of [__] it's multiple
spokes of [__] all pointing at the same
thing
um and yeah I uh
I think that busyness point you might is
really important actually
I think sometimes they just there just
was no time to think
to Think Through what they were doing
what's happened to kids now
so jizz is still open it's it's it has
lost a lot of Staff recently and I was
talking to
um a parent of someone being seen there
at the moment who has said this has been
quite difficult because it's made
continuity of care really quite tricky
being having lots of different
clinicians so they've lost a lot of
Staff they're still open
the NHS has announced last summer its
plan to to close it and it's going to be
replaced by
um Regional services in the in England
um two to start with but then the idea
is that they'll they'll be maybe seven
or eight
um and that will hopefully
address
sort of the the busyness issue which is
you can't have one Clinic attending to
all the children of one country it's
crazy but also there is a very different
approach that's been signaled that these
new services will take So So Gone is any
mention of you know a time limited
assessment whereas the the current
um
document that guides jids talks about
three to six sessions that an assessment
will be carried out there's there's just
no mention of that the primary focus is
going to be psychosocial and and
psychological so talking it's going to
be the primary aim is reducing distress
it's going to be far more holistic much
more mental health support for young
people
um expertise in all these other factors
that we've talked about in autism in
other neurodiverse conditions
safeguarding expertise
and now what they have said is that
these gaps in the evidence base which
have been identified by the systematic
evidence review they've got to be
plugged we can't just continue with no
long-term data or
um a really clear view on who benefits
from this treatment and who who might
not benefit and what the long-term
impact might be so what they've said is
that uh physical transition and access
to puberty blockers probably will still
be available but young people will be
expected to enroll onto a research
program
um so that some of that data can start
to be
to be collected and and and actually on
the point of data as we as we've
discussed
these new services are going to have
routine and consistent data collection
which doesn't appear to have been the
case over the last
30 plus years but but in the meantime
there are at least
seven and a half thousand young people
waiting on a waiting list for help some
of them waiting for years in distress
and with nothing and that's awful one of
the reframes that I'm going to take away
from your work is that when we talk
about that when we talk about seven and
a half thousand uh young people that are
struggling with what they are saying is
gender identity and for
some of them very well may be
they require
trained counseling
and interventions uh
to help them work out what's going on
that this could be from all manner of
different places and the reason that I
think it's that's such an important
takeaway is that that's politically
neutral ideologically it should be
relatively neutral look there are lots
of Contra indicators and and precursors
to what can manifest and present as a
gender identity problem
that should be treated regardless of
what it like okay so you're not going to
treat you know even the most
hard-carrying Evangelical like hard
writing what you don't want to treat a
kid that's got ADHD or OCD or Autism
like of course not like don't be an
idiot
um so I think that that's that's very
important to think about it that way as
in look there are a suite of things
going on here it is important that we
give people
um
even if you know and I'm sure teenagers
belligerent coming in saying that they
know what the problem is and they've
read it on Tick Tock or on Reddit or
whatever and blah blah blah
even if what ends up happening is that
uh OCD autism spectrum disorder Etc
counseling is couched within a gender uh
care
uh World gender care treatment which
will perhaps encourage teenagers who
wouldn't have gone for this kind of
treatment because they are adamant that
it's one issue and it may be something
else even if you do frame it within that
that very well make may make them more
open to it they go okay and then perhaps
over time if some of these uh like
issues mental health issues which are
perhaps Upstream uh from this problem if
they do get relieved you go
that's another way perhaps of dealing
with this and you know again
the massive influx that we've seen and
you mentioned it earlier on that there
are uh pockets of uh sort of gender
issues that occur it's you know five
girls in one class in one school
well I mean what's going on here like
that that seems to push against the it's
simply the fact that people are seeing
that they can live their true selves
because they're less you know there are
Role Models out there in the world well
if that was the case it would be
completely evenly distributed if there
was no sense of a psychological
influence a psychological contagion
effect like some sort of mimetic thing
that's going on
it would be exclusively distributed
randomly and evenly but it's not it
happens in in particular towns in
particular cities in particular schools
in particular classrooms I'm sure that
if you mapped the place that these kids
sit at
the lunch table where they sit in class
you're also going to see that it happens
within friend groups
so given that you have this massive
increase I actually think you know if
the UK is able to enact what it is that
you're talking about
I actually think that that's quite
reassuring I think that you know all of
the different
propositions care security safety uh
holistic model focusing on talk therapy
etc etc
that that to me seems like a pretty
unobjectionable
good approach to this issue yeah I mean
the mood music is very positive I think
the problem is we're quite a long way
from that actually being realized but I
think it's interesting that of the
countries that have looked at the
evidence base they've all started to
proceed slightly more cautiously when it
comes to medical transition they haven't
ruled it out but you know Sweden Finland
Norway potentially here in England as
well
that there's a
there's a sort of rowing back from from
affirmation only and and medical
approach only and it's it's talking
therapies first and not ruling it out to
those for whom
it will still be the right answer but
but it but not the only answer for all
of the young people coming forward
um
yeah
I really appreciate how uh
gentle you are with this discussion
that's the best that's the best word
that like the best proxy I can come up
with for I think incredibly measured
um which I think is very important you
know if you want to try and change
people's opinions if you want to try and
slice through a very divisive and sort
of ideologically fueled topic I think
that you're going about the right way
I'm very very impressed with the way
that you present your stuff so if the
people that are listening want to find
out more about you and the work that you
do why should they go
well I I work at the BBC so I don't have
a my own website or anything but um yeah
find me on Twitter I'm at Hannah SB so
Hannah
and then s b double e
um the book's called time to think it's
on in the States you can get it on
Amazon I don't have a US publisher so if
there's anyone listening and wants to
publish it then please do get in touch
but you can buy it on Amazon on Kindle
or hard copy it will be sent from in the
UK
um yeah that's me really hello I
appreciate you thank you for today
thanks so much for your time thanks for
having me what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
foreign